and when my hair is in two puffs
i'm above the clouds like a superhero
my hair even does magic tricks
uh please add book narrator to blue ivy
carter's resume
thanks i'm very happy yeah beyonce and
jay-z's eight-year-old daughter already
has a resume that looks better than
most grown-ups and on monday it got even
better
director writer producer and oscar
winner matthew a cherry shared the cover
of his children's book hair love on
instagram
along with a snippet of the audiobook
which is narrated by
little miss booked and busy herself one
day
rocky and i were playing outside when
along
came the rain from large small
it went presto just like that
there's nothing my hair can't do i mean
i'm impressed and so is her grandma
beyonce's mama
tina knowles lawson for blue to be a
part of it
it's amazing tina posted the clip to
instagram too
writing in part quote she killed it
today i woke up
extra early all by myself i was too
excited to sleep
it's a big day daddy was still
sleeping shh i said to rocky
as we tiptoed past him of course this is
hardly the first time
blue has shown off her talent
forgiveness because we're fighting
something way bigger
you never lose we a winner earlier this
year she was featured in her famous
mama's
visual album black is king a lot
like a whole lot when you're in the room
they
know she even sang on the track brown
skin girl
proving that the apple really didn't
fall far from the
thing in the tree we never treat you for
anybody else singing
yeah that collab one blue the bet her
award in june
making her the show's youngest award
winner ever
and get this blues talent expands beyond
music too she's quite a makeup artist
her grandma shared
this selfie on instagram last month
rocking skeleton makeup
courtesy of blue i bought blue so many
makeup kits
much to her her dad's dismay but um
yeah because you know dads don't like
that but uh it's just for playtime
okay we have fun she's amazing what is
like her specialty
eyes oh my gosh she puts stones and does
all this fancy stuff she can do a
perfect cat eye